this is a production of Cornell
University
all right good afternoon everyone um
today I'm gonna be talking about
greeting for weak competitive ability
and on naked organic cards so negative
aw what is naked barley on naked barley
is simply barley when harvested the hall
falls off the grain in a similar fashion
to week on we are currently bringing it
in the organic context and so we're
trying to develop on different ways to
evaluate it in New York State on three
methods that we're doing this is doing
acre grow outs for marketing on
diversity panels and our regional yield
child's which I'll go into more detail
some of the big challenges associated
with growing naked organic barley with
New York and crew food and Multan
Standards disease pressure and a lot of
agronomic pressures from New York State
environment and especially ones that are
relevant to organic conditions one an
important organic condition on factor is
we competitive ability or WCA we
competitive ability on it's defined as
an ability for a crop to tolerate or
out-compete on we pressure
weed pressure um it's a significant
problem in organic systems because on
obviously they don't have as much access
to herbicides and in addition for
evaluation experiments it's very
difficult
um to look at because weeds are very
nice are very influenced by the
environment and crop rotations so last
year we went about trying to develop
develop methods to evaluate we
competitive ability by looking at on
measurements of the weeds on by looking
at what kind of weeds were in the pots
on made a visual percentage estimation
did some weed counts and then did some
measurements of barley growth including
stain grunt stain counts early plant
height a visual barley percentage in our
categorical visual bigger ratings so
last year um I presented on this and
overall we didn't have a high
correlation yield we also had a
particularly rough environment
for growing barley on 2018 year and
while we did have some correlation for
the barley at mate 16 summate 29th we
determined that visual estimates and
categorical video of vigour ratings are
not quantitative enough to measure
barley grills so for this project we
turned to using kind of high-throughput
aerial imaging techniques to quantify
barley growth so aerial imaging from our
UAVs can measure multi spectral bands
that are reflected from the barley
particularly for our interest we're
focused on the near-infrared and
rhetoric wavelengths and finding the
differences over a ratio that is known
as normal differentiate vegetation index
and this can serve as a measurement of
vegetative biomass in a plot our aim is
if we can measure this growth and
measure the rate of growth it can
out-compete weeds early in the season
before the weeds can become more
established and then start competing
with the bark so on for the experiment
on the field design and management we
had two locations on free ville and
caldwell free ville is a with a much
more non-distressed ideal environment
for growing barley and the call location
had a lot more stress on there's 20
entries with three replications and a
randomized complete block design and
this for management on free Ville was
planted in April 23rd Caldwell in April
24th I'm grown under organic conditions
and one special thing that we did have
to do is that we did have to get rid of
the weeds in the plots on because if we
did not it would not be possible to
differentiate the NDVI between the weeds
in the barley on this field is the Colo
one as you can see there is significant
variation within this field particularly
among a row so
aerial image collection flights were
conducted using it make ascents red edge
camera using a DJI 100 drone on flights
were conducted 25 meters which gives a
resolution about 2 centimeters per pixel
for ground truth undie VI we used a
tremble green seeker and we used an r TK
system for therefore ground control
points per location the timeline for the
flights we conducted seven for each
location we started at about 30 days
after planting and ended about 70 on
images of the calibration of reflectance
panel were taken before and after each
flight and flights were conducted within
three hours a solution we got about 68
to 75 on images of 5 spectral bands of
per field on used AG to softpro stitch
the images together and then to extract
mean NDVI values i used on image read
developed by nick Morales on part of
green base and here you can see some of
the plot polygons that were undeveloped
on fer to the location of free fill so
overall for free Ville between the
correlation of ground truth valley
estate on aerial imaging failures the
correlations were quite high at the
beginning in the end but at the middle
on their quite low on two reasons for
this could be either on the there's some
error and my part of the measuring the
UAV gente VI on but in addition the
ground truth on green seeker can only
measure for two significant figures so
like point seven nine to 0.8 0.8 one so
it may have been not able to capture the
differences
however in Caldwell we had much higher
correlations and that might be due to
the contrast of the stressful
environment on that provided much more
accurate on correlations so on a free
build these are the distributions of the
NDVI values on green on is the aerial
imaging and blues the ground truth and
early in the season at free Ville the
the variation on decreased early early
in days after planting and then on kind
of a decrease and then increased again
hey Caldwell however there is much more
on even variation uses the stress and
lack of nutrients on at Caldwell so on I
calculated heritability on for each time
point on at free ville I've I used this
model on the response at the NDVI value
just an intercept mean and a random
effector phenotype overall heritability
x' were high on with the exception in
this time point on in the middle of
planting and in calls well I use this
model with the only addition as I used a
fixed effector a row to account for the
significant row effect sigh mentioned
earlier and heritability Z were quite a
bit lower in terms of a
correlations to other traits on you
there's only about 0.5 to correlation
for the later on days after planting
heading date there was a correlation for
the early growth which would make sense
if you have higher vegetative growth
earlier on in the season on my head
heading date will be higher on
surprisingly there is no correlation
author for height that could be captured
by the aerial and on aerial imaging and
there were some correlation to disease
as a spot watch for Caldwell on there
was a significant on correlation for you
on heading date that was not not much on
in this system I the correlations were
able to capture height differences and
there was some correlation to spot watch
on in the future I hope to model this a
little bit more dynamically and
utilizing kind of growth for curve
functions per line across environments
I hope the work on miles addressing the
spatial variability in the field um hope
to develop prediction models for some of
these traits and then hopefully use
these models by such for potential
selection and I would like to thank
everyone on to help me out with this
committee members mark Gary and Sam of
everyone the lab group special thanks to
everyone with helping me with aerial
imaging um I was learning how to do that
including Margaret on Nick all three
nights and of course a Jannik lab group
in synapses
[Applause]
so it's part of what you're getting
after is is you know competitiveness
with weeds yep why did you choose in DVI
versus looking at like fine hyper or
canopy coverage as your phenotype
so um hmm NDVI seemed like it would be
the best way to kind of capture the
canopy coverage but um I'd realized
there might be models that might be
better for that but on how I hide
something we thought we could put in the
model but I doesn't like measures last
year didn't seem to capture that as much
so we're hoping that it like on NDVI
would capture more like a wide leaf
angle so to speak if the parlays to
capture that there can be but it's very
still even then it's still very
difficult to measure because on there
might be we distributions but yeah
they're not they're much more located
with respect to the field like last year
you'll have a certain corner of the
field that has a certain kind of weed
and then another they'll have another
fight it's just very difficult to
control for what kind of weeds on pop up
in the certain areas but Carl do you
have notes on - there's two main growth
evidence for early prostrate and erect
so there's something like really light
on the ground for a long time of it or
there a break the whole way you have
notes on that yes and all dan asked if I
have a notes on prostate versus direct
on yes and currently there's only really
one line that is that is like is not
erect its prostrate on so yeah I do and
I didn't find a significant difference
with those either the rate of growth
early on so a lot of competing
to rapid growth mm-hmm nation is that a
trait sure um yeah hopefully next year
um we I hope to aim to do this as soon
as it's planted and look at even earlier
stages but on in developing this
protocol is a learning process
I'm do imaging when should we start when
should we finish ship its what was the
nature of the stress between the two
locations and was it intentional it was
not intentional on that's what came out
of sales that's why it isn't not
intentional in that but these are how
organic fields can be put on probably
the most the most probable cause for the
stress is probably nutrient availability
I mean these were playing at the same
time on so it was you know it's probably
nutrient availability at the couple
location I haven't gotten into that yet
but I would like to alright if there are
no more questions or sumn please join me
one more time and thanking Carla
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu